Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and recently
there has been a lot of stuff going down behind
the scenes with the Marvel Universe.
Robert Downey Jr. said no plans for Iron Man
4, which was kind of expected and on the other
side of the coin, Dave Bautista is going through
some contract changes that would allow him
to play a bigger part in the movies.
Also as you may have noticed, I’ve got a
bunch of comments that people like the old
set better.
I just moved to a new apartment and I’m
still setting up my new studio.
So this is what things will look like temporarily.
But the big tease is that his new deal will
allow Bautista ato guest star in the next
Avengers movie.
I’ll explain what it all really means.
If you’re just finding me for the first
time, I do Marvel videos every week and Agents
of SHIELD when it comes back so be sure to
subscribe to get everything.
Just to explain the Robert Downey Jr stuff
real quick, it’s not that they absolutely
won’t make Iron Man 4.
It’s just that Marvel is allowing Robert
Downey Jr. to either come up with a script
or pass on the armor.
He also gets to pick his own successor.
So the next Tony Stark will be cast by Robert
Downey Jr himself.
It won’t happen till well after Avengers
3, so we can talk about that later.
Drax the Destroyer is the new young gun.
If you remember, during Guardians when Peter
Quill kept going on and on about how awesome
earth was, Drax said.
I shall have to go there one day…
That wasn’t specifically intended to be
a teaser.
Just one of those Marvel Universe lines where
the writer.
In this case, James Gunn, was leaving room
for the future.
But James Gunn didn’t know what the whole
Marvel Phase 3 plan was before making Guardians
or anything.
Usually when first movies like that get made,
because there’s always a risk they could
flop.
They’re written to be a little more self-contained.
Unlike say Captain America The Winter Soldier.
Which basically crumbled the SHIELD glue that
was holding all the Earth-Based movies together.
I always viewed SHIELD, Samuel Jackson and
Agent Coulson as the one common thread across
all the phase 1 movies.
Now it’s starting to turn into the infinity
gems and Thanos’ quest.
Based on the pacing so far it seems like they’ll
stretch that out all across phase 3.
So if you haven’t read any comics about
the infinity gauntlet, don’t worry.
You still have a long time to catch up.
Eventually everyone will have to come together
and stop Thanos, The Guardians will have to
overlap with The Avengers.
That’s also something that isn’t happening
before Guardians 2, that movie is currently
scheduled for 2017.
James Gunn has already confirmed that there
will be no more humans joining the team.
There will be another female though.
But Drax has become the center of the crossover
talk.
There has to be a reason for the guardians
and the avengers to meetup.
They won’t just meet for shawarma.
The easy way in to a full blown crossover
is by letting one character guest star in
the other’s movie.
Previously it was rumored that Hulk would
be guest starring in a future Guardians movie.
Whether or not that’s still the case.
Now it’s all about Marvel re-working Dave
Bautista’s contract to allow him to be in
an Avengers movie.
Hold the phone though, I know some of your
are wondering, if only Drax is going to guest
star in Avengers 3, does that mean they won’t
do the infinity gauntlet?
It kind of sounds like it.
It’s totally possible that Marvel could
wait till phase 4 to bring all of the gems
together.
As it stands, there are only two more gems
we haven’t seen yet.
The Time Gem and the Soul Gem.
So one possible solution that would allow
them to prolong the Thanos Infinity Quest
storyline would be to have the gems trade
hands a couple of times.
Like at the end of Thor the Dark World.
The Reality Gem aka the Aether, is given to
the Collector.
Imagine someone steals it from him, things
like that will probably happen over the course
of phase 3.
Loki’s staff is pretty much the mind gem.
And it went from Thanos, to Loki, to the Avengers,
to Baron Von Strucker and presumably at the
end of the movie, back to the avengers.
So the big question is what story would Avengers
3 be, that it requires Drax the Destroyer
but not the Guardians?
I know a lot of you have asked me if they’ll
do Civil War as a possible storyline.
I don’t think they will, just because Winter
Soldier had a lot of the DNA of Civil War.
Basically eliminating every superhero on the
planet and the idea of a big government conspiracy.
Usually the sequels do a good job of following
up the preceding movie with a logical next
step.
So Avengers 2 is picking up where Winter Soldier
leaves off.
Cleaning up all the remnants of HYDRA all
over the world.
So if Ultron is going to create an army of
replicants to take over the world, the avengers
will first have to neutralize him somehow
and then deal with the cleanup again.
It’s a little too soon to speculate on Avengers
3 beyond that just because Joss Whedon is
always really good at surprising with left
turns.
I’m really hoping to see Carol Danvers and
a tease for the rest of Phase 3.
As of right now, the only confirmed projects
are Ant-Man which is in the middle of shooting,
Doctor Strange, which is still locking down
an actor, Guardians 2, which is in pre-production,
Avengers 3, which is also in pre-production
and Black Panther.
Which is searching for a director and a script
re-write.
The Inhumans movie and the Miss Marvel or
Captain Marvel movie, how ever you want to
think about it are also in development, but
no word on which order we’ll see them.
The big takeaway from all the Drax talk is
that the avengers guardians crossover will
be more of a guest appearance before it becomes
a full blown team up.
If you didn’t see it, some promo art for
the vision leaked recently.
He looks pretty much like he does in the comics.
But you can
also see the finished Avengers Tower in the
background.
There are a few people missing from this picture,
but you get the idea.
It’s all about The Vision.
I’ve already done a bunch of videos about
him.
So if you want to learn more about his origins
in the movie universe click here.
They will be different than the comics.
And click here to learn about my fall schedule.
All the videos I’m working on this fall.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!